unless one piece pulls a major final
twist that ends the story in absolute
tragedy we can pretty much say for
certain that Luffy will become pirate
king defeat all the big baddies and
change the world but then what what is
going to happen to all of the straw hats
and most importantly what will the one
piece World overall look like 10 years
after the world has been saved but
luckily we know pretty much exactly what
many of our favorite characters would
probably be up to based on their dreams
and a lot of foreshadowing that we got
in the story like Sanji who at this
point will definitely have found the
all-blue and Robin who will finally
learn the true history of the world but
then there's of course Luffy himself who
at this point will have actually already
achieved his dream and if I'm being
completely honest my personal bet would
be that Luffy actually dies at the end
of the series because he is kind of this
jesus-like figure throughout the story
that I can totally see sacrificing
himself to save everyone else but that
being said let's say a positive here and
assume that he actually survives like
maybe Chopper somehow heals all the
lifespan that he's lost and now he is
the freest man in the world which now
takes us 10 years into the future where
Luffy is about to set out on his next
major adventure and so he steps out of
his family home on New Dawn Island and
what is this new unheard of Island well
it's a new island formed after the
collapse of the red line where all the
races of the world have now basically
come to live together in harmony and let
me tell you this island would be
absolutely insane the main part would
probably be jam-packed with houses
stores and a massive party area in the
center because of course it is Luffy's
Island and what else really would he
rather do than party all the time with
all his friends and speaking of those
friends here's a shocker for you Luffy
after the story I think would be married
and has a four-year-old daughter named
Lily but we'll save the surprise of who
actually managed to tie this rubber band
down for a little bit later for now
Luffy is on a mission he wants to throw
a massive party for his kids fifth
birthday and so of course that means
inviting his friends all of his friends
but of course there is one big problem
for this only some of the former
strawhead Pirates actually live on this
island which ones you ask well we'll see
in just a moment as Luffy does leave
home with just his straw hat and a bag
full of invitations but before setting
out he has a few invitations to actually
deliver around his islands and while
he's on his way out we can see what an
incredibly diverse plays New Dawn island
has actually become and that's because
many of the people that we witnessed
Luffy befriending on his journey to
become pirate king have actually decided
to come and live here there are some
fishmen Mings mermaids Giants tontata
Sky peons all going about their business
within the various districts of the town
which are filled with shops and
restaurants from all across the one
piece worlds there is even an amusement
park and a giant Music Arena in the very
center of the islands which of course is
let's be real exactly what you would
expect Luffy's Island design to look
like so let's now explore the rest of
this place because Luffy hops over to
the first of these mini Islands here and
these are actually pretty neat I think
because they house some of his closest
friends for example this one right here
closest to Luffy's house is actually
Sanji and his wife puddings world famous
five-star restaurant the restaurant is
basically the completion of sanji's
dream since Newton Island is located
right in the middle of the famous all
blue which is where all the four C's
join together and while of course there
is no 100 guarantee to know for certain
that this will happen in the actual
story I do personally think that it is
pretty likely that the red line will
actually be destroyed at least the part
where the reverse mountain is because I
mean come on it's basically a big giant
x mark already that is marking the spot
here and if this part is destroyed that
will leave space for Newton Islands to
form out of the rubble and so Luffy just
swings straight through the front door
pops his first invitation into sanji's
Chef head and then grabs all of the food
that Sanji and his hard-working chefs
have spent hours preparing stuffs it all
into his giant sack for this long trip
around the world and at first Sanji is
understandably Furious and chases after
Luffy bed after he actually stops and
reads the invitation He Just Smiles so
that's a one straw head down many more
to go and Luffy's next stop is this
little island which is home to two world
famous buildings the first here is a
University founded by the greatest
archaeologist in the world Nico Robin
she created this place with her good
body Soul so that anyone who wanted to
study archeology and the ancient past
could just gather here to learn but as
Luffy barges into Robin's office he
finds that she's apparently out on some
sort of grand Expedition so I guess
she's the first one we have to add to
our list of straw hats to find out
somewhere in the one piece world and so
he then hops over to the hospital on the
other half of the islands where Dr
Chopper and Dr law can basically cure
any disease and they have even developed
this super cool bird ambulance system
which can bring in patients from all
over the world but that's now Chopper
and law both invited check because next
up is this Middle Island which is
actually where most of the patients of
the hospital actually come from why is
that well it's because this little
island houses jimbei's Fishman karate
school where he trains anyone who wants
to learn how to fight alongside this
former Fishman revolutionary here and so
that's uh Jimbo invited and on the same
island is the massive never lost Dojo as
well where anyone can come and learn the
way of the sword and this place is
really cool because Zorro actually hosts
monthly tournaments for anyone wanting
to challenge his title as the world's
strongest swordsman which you know if
we're being honest it's probably a good
idea that people actually come to him
because we all know he'd absolutely just
get lost trying to find strong opponents
so like he really developed a smart
system here but for some mysterious
reason he is also off the island right
now and I do wonder what he might be
doing out in the world and after leaving
the dojo Luffy then flies over to the
brightest of the little Islands which is
funnily enough called Golden Island I
wonder who named it that way as we'll
find out soon enough on this island is a
massive Casino run by the former warlord
crocodile and when Luffy goes inside he
finds his old Mentor Rayleigh hanging
out with his new gambling buddy kizaru
yeah apparently after the Lightfoot user
left the Marines these two quickly
became gambling buddies plus kizeru's
light speed is super helpful when
Rayleigh needs to escape whenever his
longtime lover demands he actually
brings home some money and right next to
the casino is the local branch of the
Tangerine bank and who is the head of
the Tangerine bank well you guessed it
it's none other than the grown-up otama
who trained under a certain cat burglar
that we all know and love but where in
the world would she be running a bank
well uh keep watching to find out in
just a bit but now now there is one more
stop before Luffy can finally leave the
islands and that is the research lab on
the final Little Island right here and
this is where all the fun starts because
as soon as Luffy arrives a massive
explosion shakes the islands out of the
smoke comes a giant version of his
grandpa Garb Loki is actually super
excited to see a mega sized garbut that
instantly changes when his Grandpa's
massive fist comes rushing straight
towards him but just as the fist is
about to crush Luffy it explodes into
flashing lights and Sparks and then out
of the smoke Comes The Genius scientist
Dr vegapung Who can barely keep himself
from laughing at his hologram prank you
see after the events at the end of the
story vegapunk decided to set up shop
right here with Luffy on new Don Island
and even though he doesn't get all that
Limitless funding from the world
government that he used to he can still
make some pretty awesome stuff to help
out the world so yeah Luffy will
definitely be spending some time at
least playing around with some of Vega
Punk's fun new technology which you can
actually see and use all over the town
and then Luffy does leave him with some
instructions for the party as well and
with that Luffy jumps over to the other
side of the main island he stops by
usop's house but he is also curiously
missing he identifies past this tiny new
government building that no one really
cares about and skips right to the new
Frankie family Warehouse which is of
course where Frankie comes up with all
of his crazy new inventions as well and
the most important of those is probably
the new and improved version of the C
train which is currently leaving the
station at warp speed now Luffy somehow
manages to stretch and grab on and his
new adventure to invite all of his
friends is now fully underway and as he
leaves a giant hologram off his face
appears in the sky above the island
announcing his daughter's birthday party
to everyone who is there and of course a
massive cheer Rises up throughout the
islands Luffy smiles and it does seem
like vegapunk understood his message
just fine however despite how awesome
Luffy's new home Island actually is he
would probably be really excited to head
out to sea after so much time doing
nothing plus there's still six other
former crewmates and a ton of other
important friends and characters to find
out in the world which now brings us to
a super important part of this specific
scenario because now that we're setting
out into the world we need to know what
exactly has happened to the world after
Luffy became pirate king and while while
we don't know for certain of course
there are a few things that will most
likely happen at the end of one piece
Luffy will find the one piece and become
pirate king because if not what have I
done with my life for the last 10 years
he will also take down the corrupt World
Nobles and bring the dawn to the world
which basically means setting the world
free and so these few things at least
are basically guaranteed to happen
unless Oda Sensei pulls some sort of
crazy twist that no one's expecting and
I'm sure it'll be super easy to find a
new perfect political system that has no
problem at all ruling an entire planet
but let's skip over it and for now just
assume that there is a new government
that works way better than the last one
now there are still Pirates even bad
pirates but the good Pirates and Marines
now do a really good job of keeping
everyone from doing so much damage and
with Luffy having such a diverse crew
there is much less discrimination
against other races throughout the world
which is actually part of Frankie's
purpose for creating the new C train
system which will eventually connect the
entire world together and this is
actually really important for Luffy's
current Journey as well because as we
all know Luffy could never get anywhere
sailing on his own and so the first stop
after New Dawn island is actually elbaf
because we're going in the reverse
direction of the grand line where Luffy
now brings some invitations to the new
leaders of the Giants and actually these
days not only giants live on elbaf
because after making friends with usop
they are of course open to anyone who
wants to become a brave Warrior of the
sea and Luffy was actually hoping to
find both Shanks and usob right here but
it does seem that the Giants seen Shanks
around in a while and Usopp seems to be
out adventuring with his dad who does
have a lot of making up to do and
finally I will say because it took 10
years for most of the deadbeat dads in
the world to actually spend time with
their kids and so now back on the train
Luffy's next stop is juano but suddenly
a massive explosion rocks the train now
the train itself is fine because I mean
Frankie made it and have you seen the
kind of stuff that Frankie makes but
Luffy looks out of the window and he
sees this massive ship speeding towards
the train and while the other passengers
freak out Luffy is thrilled to see buggy
who is the new ruler of pirate island of
course however buggy does seem fairly
determined to take out the train and
Luffy comes out to stop him however as
Luffy is about to charge up a gomugomo
attack he hears an incredibly familiar
voice shouting from the top of the train
he turns around and is absolutely
shocked to find out that his
four-year-old daughter Lily is shouting
insults at the buggy Pirates Who are
coming across the waves and before he
can stop her she jumps up catches a
cannonball and throws it back at the
oncoming ship which sounds ridiculous
but this is Luffy's kid after all and
then seemingly out of nowhere a giant
ship from albov appears and cuts off
Buggy's ship allowing the train to
continue on without Luffy having to even
fight because this is actually part of
the Allied country's jobs to protect the
sea train route that is connecting all
of them together but now that Luffy's
kid is on board all he can really do is
laugh and take her along for the right
though I bet that Luffy's wife is not
going to be happy at all when he returns
anyways onto the land of the Samurai
here Momo is still the Shogun and the
borders have finally been opened to the
rest of the world and here is where we
find our favorite green-haired swordsman
because apparently his wife who is Momo
sister hiori dragged him back to her
home to see her family but of course
when Luffy tells him about the party he
cannot resist the invitation and even
decides to join the journey to find the
other crewmates so cross off one more of
the list but that's of course not all
that is there to see in wano because
Luffy's old Marine rivaled smoker and
tashigi now run an orphanage and a sword
Museum where tashidi shows off all the
famous blades that they have collected
from bad pirates over the years you guys
really is there a better place to start
a literal sword Museum except the place
that literally makes the best lights in
the world and after wano the next step
is whole cake Island now these islands
of course used to be the home of the
emperor big mom but now our donut loving
Mochi man katakuri has created a ton of
world famous bakeries on the many
islands of tottlands and that's because
originally these islands were all themed
around food like chocolate and fluffy
cake so it's only natural really that
katakuri would want to take all of these
resources to make the absolute best
sweets in the entire world of course
deep down he really just wants to eat
the best sweets himself but he would
definitely share when Luffy and the Gang
come to drop off an invitation and so
after losing to Lily in a sweet eating
contest they all take the train to
dressrosa and I'm actually starting to
wonder if we will find any of the other
straw hats here now once they land they
see that the island has been rebuilt
from the ground up and the tribe of
dwarves who helped save the Kingdom from
the evil warlord or Flamingo 10 years
ago are now a fully integrated part of
the society here Luffy of course invites
all of his friends to the party and then
gives special instructions to Leo the
leader of the tontada to pass out the
remaining invitations to the rest of the
straw hat Grand fleets but as we'll see
at the end of this video this actually
creates a huge problem for Luffy that
we'll discuss later on now by this time
about a week has passed since Luffy left
the island and we've reached the exact
opposite side of the world which may
seem super fast to travel as far as they
have but remember the sea train was made
by Frankie so of course it is super fast
and between adventuring on islands and
practicing swords with her Uncle Lily is
having the time of her life but we've
only found Zorro so far so where is
everyone else and what about Luffy's
brother or his dad what's everyone up to
but in this super important location
which used to be where marijua was
located is this new island right here
which is also the headquarters of the
newly established government of the
world the way I would see it is that
after the fall of the previous
government the world would basically
just take out the celestial dragons and
other evil rulers and make some sort of
new system of government with elected
officials from Allied kingdoms and even
some pirate Crews and while this system
probably is also not perfect let's be
honest no government really is Luffy's
brother Sabo now spends his days
basically watching over the new
government to make sure any corruption
is stamped out completely at least
that's what he's supposed to be doing
when he's not chewing down on delivery
orders of sanji's world famous Ramen
however Sabo does agree to take time off
and Luffy also drops off an invitation
for the new Marine Admiral Kobe as well
however as great as it is to see his
brother Luffy doesn't care to stick
around the government for long so they
quickly hop back on the train and
continue their Adventure which takes
them back to the location of the
original c train on water 7 where surely
we have to meet another straw hat right
now this island is completely different
from when we first visited it in the
original story and that's because it
isn't even an island anymore remember
that water 7 was sinking because of
these giant waves but that is no longer
an issue because together Frankie and
the mayor of water 7 Iceberg finally
managed to transform the entire city
into one Giant floating ship Frankie has
of course also decked out his former
home with some fun new technology but
the most incredible invention of all of
it is a fleet of massive balloons which
allows the people to safely reach
skypier which is exactly where the gang
Heads next and it is up in the clouds
that they finally meet up with some old
friends that's because usop and yasop
are both having a friendly sniping
competition trying to snipe the Golden
Bell from miles away but right next to
them is one of the few honorary straw
hats as well Yamato that's right Yamato
has finally got now to explore the world
just like she promised at the end of the
wano arc and boy is she happy to see
Luffy in fact after that competition
they finally drop off all the
invitations with their Skype and friends
and then usop and Yamato yes this time
for real both join the group and head
back down to the surface and we finally
got some other straw heads back on board
that I'm seriously hoping that the
others didn't just die or something
because we where where are they however
there is one major problem coming up
ahead and that's because the train
doesn't continue on forever it's not
completed you see when the train reaches
the end of the tracks the group finally
finds Frankie who is working with his
new crew of cyborg construction workers
to complete the C train tracks but no
train means no more free rides but this
isn't really an issue for long because
Frankie has the Thousand Sunny with him
and so when Luffy asked Frankie of
course agrees to come with them on their
trip so the gang along with our super
cyborg continue onward from here which
brings us to Alabaster where it's
basically raining straw hats Alabaster
has actually become a world famous hot
spring destination at this point thanks
a bunch garnetsu and Vivi is currently
of course ruling the kingdom after her
dad passed away but politics are not
currently on her mind at all because she
is rocking out at a concert for the
worldwide music phenomenon Soul King
Brooke that's right Australian skeleton
has gone back to being a rock star and
he traveled the world with his whale
friend laboon and he's not the only
former Straw Hat here though because
Robin is also enjoying the concert while
taking a break from studying in the
Royal Alabaster library and so after
enjoying the concert Vivi Brooke and
Robin all joined with the crew and
together with the moon tailing behind
them they set out for what used to be
the East blue and here they enter the
domain of the mega Rich Bank CEO Nami
which might surprise you but after
finishing her map of the entire world
Nami sold her completed navigational
charts and made a fortune she then took
all that money started a worldwide
banking group Tangerine Banks and has
basically become the richest person in
the one piece world I guess at this
point she doesn't need to charge even
her friends 300 interest anymore she
even has bought everyone in her hometown
a massive Mansion to buy back all the
trouble that she cost as a kid but when
her friends arrive Luffy's former
Navigator drops everything to give Lily
a giant hug and then she immediately
takes over sailing the ship with the
crew which now is all of the crew but
there are still some super important
people left to find and so the next stop
is Luffy's Hometown the former Goa
Kingdom however upon arrival they
immediately run into trouble cannonballs
start raining splashing down everywhere
around the ship and that's of course
because Luffy's grandfather GARP is
still alive and chucking the missiles at
the ship from the shoreline while
Luffy's father Dragon lounges nearby
eating his favorite greasy sandwiches
however after they land and Lily
proceeds to beat up her
great-grandfather Luffy invites the two
to the party back on udon islands and
Shanks also comes down to meet the Gang
at the beach and he is joined by the
barchipamakino and their own baby boy
who is now around 10 years old already
and honestly of course it's entirely
possible that none of these three super
powerful Fighters might be alive at the
end of the story but for now we don't
know so I'm just going to add all of
them anyways and so now with all the
invitations delivered it is time to head
back to New Dawn Island where with all
of his friends United he throws one of
the greatest parties the world has ever
seen to celebrate Lily's birthday
including of course Luffy's wife Boa
Hancock which is of course the best case
scenario for what could happen after one
piece but what if things actually went
horribly wrong for Luffy and his friends
along the way and instead of becoming
pirate king Luffy was instead captured
and sentenced to death to be executed by
the world government and it's just
absolutely insane to think about all the
people who would come to rescue him that
I just had to make an entire video to
see if Luffy would actually survive and
you can watch that right here thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one